you should definitely be sampling both
sides of the news if you're not looking
at Fox News and CNN you don't know
what's happening hey this is the Reuben
report and according to the paperwork
i'm still dave rubin just a quick
reminder guys to subscribe to the
channel and click that bell over there
YouTube's really been crushing us on the
recommended videos so it's most likely
the only way you'll get to see our clips
all right then joining me today is the
creator of the legendary Dilbert comic
strip and the author of the new book
loser think Scott Adams welcome back to
the Reuben report thanks for having me
third time man they say better every
time they say three times is the charm
first off before I ask you anything else
because you're a man of persuasion how
was my intro there in terms of
persuasion do you think I persuaded
people to actually click the Bell to
actually subscribe was i heavy-handed
enough was i subtle enough you might
need a little technique yes you know you
need to tell them there's just shortage
all their friends are doing it
everybody's talking about it you don't
want to miss it limited edition we might
take that button away if you don't click
it and you might never be able to
subscribe if you don't do it right now
those are crazy examples but yeah
there's probably another level you could
take that there's probably another level
I should be hire you on retainer or
something to just deal with my YouTube
problems and how to get people to
subscribe and that sort of answer I need
another job somehow I really doubt you
need another job I'm pretty busy running
down with the book yeah yeah all right
so we're gonna talk a lot about the book
but for for anyone that just hasn't seen
our interviews or for some reason has
never come across Dilbert or is not
watching you drink coffee on Twitter
let's just do the the Scott Adams
two-minute bio of sort of what got you
into first the cartoon strip and then
now being an author and sort of a
de-facto leader of the deplorable Zahn
line in a weird way wow that for a
question where would you like me to
start well just let's just recap the
career quick all right well I was one of
those I didn't see the other two
interviews I was working in my cubicle
jobs for 16 years when I was a younger
man and those those careers had a glass
ceiling in both cases I can tell this
story now I couldn't tell it at the time
but in both cases my boss called me into
the office and said we got caught with
no diversity and senior management and
so until further notice you're a white
male
we can't promote you they send it
directly that's not an interpretation
yeah so after the second company told me
that I left the first one for telling me
that I went to the phone company they
told me the same thing after I was there
for a while
and I said I got to find it a way to not
have a boss and so I tried a few things
cartooning was one of them sure sure
story long I submitted materials to the
major syndications
one liked it enough to say yes so
cartooning begins that goes well Dilbert
and Dilbert turned out okay it did okay
yeah yeah now I like to give the context
because it sounds like you know I went
right to it and you know gold but I
tried other things I tried to be a
programmer I tried to write other things
etc this was just the thing that worked
and then time goes by and there's this
this president Trump situation occurred
first candidate Trump and I was not
intending to make any kind about pivot
I just noticed he had some skills that I
thought I could see that others couldn't
because I'm a trained hypnotist and I've
been studying persuasion and all of its
various forums so when I saw him I
thought well it'd be useful for the
country to know that this isn't an
accident that he's starting to get more
attention you notice how to do this it's
technique and so I started calling it an
IP therefore once actors that's when I
first met you you weren't even a trump
supporter at the time you were just sort
of talking about the techniques he was
using and just because of that everyone
said oh Scott Adams this mad guy he's
far right all of that nonsense not that
you were supporting some of his policies
necessarily but you were just saying
this is how he is doing these things
this is how he is gaining a following
and getting his message out right so I
identify as left of Bernie so I still do
now I still do
because socially you know I could give
you some examples but socially I do but
what I what I eventually saw in Trump is
they had a toolkit that I thought could
just do stuff other people wouldn't do
take on China
that's the toolkit you want be the best
cheerleader for the
economy literally get our psychology
work in the right direction hey
everything's good everything's good why
don't you invest okay it's the
psychology of the economy I thought
nobody's going to do that as well as him
and likewise North Korea I thought who
could who could have a meeting well
before it happened I already written
about it I said who could have a meeting
with Kim jong-un and just turn this
personal maybe find a way in president
Trump so I'm a supporter in terms of his
toolkit but you know it doesn't mean I
agree with everything he does yeah
that's a hard place to be in though
right because people don't really care
for that second part of that say it's a
it's an expensive place to be let me
tell you yes my incomes down 30% you
know they're just things I can't do
because I'm associated was saying
something too nice about his skill can
you talk about that a little bit more
like what kind of business things have
dried up or even personal friends or I
don't want to say specifically where you
live but you do live in California I
mean you live in a place that is maybe
not so hospitable to some of these ideas
let's just say there was a rebuilding
period where I had to make new friends a
lot of them you know that phase of that
building process are you in right now
well you know I'm living a very good
life with my girlfriend Christina we're
quite happy with the way things are so I
don't have a complaint there it's just
an observation
there's socially it became very
difficult to have the same friends what
was that like because I think everyone
watching this has been through that to
some degree my book is about that it's
about what happens as you start sort of
coming out of the political closet that
you sort of get thrown under the bus by
people that you thought were your
friends next thing you know there's this
whole other crew that's welcoming you it
mean it really is sort of a flip on
everything you know
yeah only only my most let's say honest
friends were willing to say it to my
face and that only happened a few times
so mostly I just noticed that my
Facebook feed started to give me it was
getting emptier and emptier that I feel
like oh really only one picture was
posted all this week by all everybody I
know that's weird and then you see that
they've unfriended you and then you
check you know their feeds and you see
what their political leaning is you put
two plus two together then here we are
yeah how does your background in
persuasion and
magic and the cartoon and everything
sort of fit your your general demeanor I
said to you right before we started that
you're one of the few people that I that
I now know that when I see them on
Twitter I don't like them less there are
so many people that I know that and what
we all are not necessary our best selves
on Twitter and online in general but I
see so many people that like I kind of
respect or I know and I'm and then I
look at their Twitter and I'm like ooh
what what is going on here and I'm sure
there's people that say that about me
too but you seem like you're pretty like
pretty much the same in both worlds but
to be fair there are a lot of people
look at my Twitter and say you're the
worst person in the world right I used
to like your comic but now I can never
laugh again yeah just in general I can
never laugh again well you get away
their ability not just to laugh at you
but the whole thing I have you noticed
that the humor has just completely
changed yeah yeah as has been said you
can't make a movie a funny movie a funny
TV show in fact if you watch like an old
Family Guy rerun the whole time I'm
sitting there thinking you couldn't make
that today I can do that but humor has
become reality
and politics and it's very entertaining
and thankfully we have the funniest
president we've ever had but so as a
satirist though what do you make of the
comedy side of this because you know
it's somebody like Seth MacFarlane who
created Family Guy you know they've said
I don't know that they're going through
with it but I remember a few months back
they it said this thing where they're
not gonna do any more gay jokes and it's
like well the show did you know 25 years
of gay jokes and now gays are equal so
this might be the time to make gay jokes
so you can you know further integrate
people into society that's what Don
Rickles did right it brought it out
together or the Simpsons you know they
were gonna take out up who for a while
and then Hank Azaria the greatest
voiceover actor of all time had to
apologize for doing an Indian accent
what do you make of the not just the
content but the people behind it you
know they've been infected I'm generally
okay with the concept that society moves
forward and things that we used to laugh
at we didn't realize we're cruel and
then maybe you grow up and say oh that
was really mean er than it needed to be
what was it wasn't really trying to do
that and so I'm okay with society
evolving but the trouble is it evolved
away all the things
that were the normal joke materials now
it didn't affect me with Dilbert because
when you're in a family newspaper
there's yeah there's a cap on what you
can do so I was always well in the
family friendly version talking about
the workplace so it didn't affect me
much but it certainly changed the
landscape of humor
probably forever yeah do you feel freer
because I think you said to me last time
you were here that you you've got some
fu money so that you can kind of be free
enough to to do what you want yeah I
mean I didn't think it would be as
expensive as it was you know maybe I
maybe I would have thought it through
but no it won't change my lifestyle and
I did recognize that I was in this
unique position where I had something to
say that in my opinion was not biased
you know it was just hey this is what
I'm saying there's a little good and
there's a little bad here so I thought
it was a unique niche niche niche yeah
I'll go with either one do you go with
I'll take either one
I shouldn't say words I never say I
allowed I would have said niche
personally but I would accept niche as I
look at your lovely decorations here I
think that you are probably right better
to figure out the critic the correct but
it feels like it says somehow I don't
know what do you make her just sort of
how that's a guy that you know you sort
of came out of newspapers as you said
that now you use all of this stuff in a
different way you know you sit in the
morning do you do it every morning
you're doing pretty pretty much every
morning right you get on Twitter what do
you have your phone just like locked on
something and you make yourself some
coffee and you just kind of talk to the
world that that's a big transition from
you know putting a cartoon in the paper
and letting it be versus this fully
interactive thing yeah the difference is
sorry yes I do
coffee with Scott Adams on the periscope
app every day and then it moves over to
YouTube but about an hour later on
replay but I started doing it because I
was just interested in the election and
there were people to talk to and I had
more to say and I didn't feel like
writing it all down all the time because
every day there'd be three new things to
talk about and then it just grew I
wasn't I didn't really have any
expectation no plan it wasn't planning
to even monetize it it just grew into a
thing and now if I miss a day because I
do it on weekends two holidays
because people are so addicted to having
the simultaneous sip as I call it so I I
do a toast of coffee with with the
public and that they miss it and so now
it's sort of labor of love I would
really really miss it like this morning
my wife I wasn't working so well and I
was like I don't know if I could do it
but I got my hotspot working and then it
made me happy right like most most
watered down it from here we want to let
you know that have been great yeah most
work doesn't make you happy mm-hmm you
know you might like your job but doesn't
make you happy
whereas doing the periscopes it's just a
joy every day yeah I actually did it one
morning I did coffee with Dave and I did
fully credit you with the coffee idea no
one was talking with coffee before you
but I did think that there was something
nice about just starting the day just
sort of unloading a couple of thoughts
just just that in and of itself I
thought was was kind of refreshing
yeah it has the unintended consequence
that I often frame things before people
wake up so if there's something that
happens say in the afternoon the the
pundits and people haven't had much time
to deal with it and sometimes I'm the
first person they hear saying well the
way to look at this is this is important
and this isn't and somewhat accidentally
I became influential do you think that's
sort of your primary skill like a sort
of framing of the craziness and what
we're obviously going to get to the book
in a little bit but I think that's sort
of what you're doing is you're helping
people frame through just like this
endless an onslaught of information so I
often say I have one superpower so I've
got one superpower and then a bunch of
like supporting talents that I've tried
to piece together over time the
superpower is simplification I'm just a
really good simplifier which is what
makes one a cartoonist cartoon is by its
definition the simplest thing you can
put in this little panel so if you can
simplify you can frame because it's
taking down all the noise focusing on
the thing that mattered so I actually
have the skill as a simplifier yeah it's
kind of funny because that's almost the
reverse of what everyone else is doing
and this sort of is what the book is
about like everyone else is pretending
they know everything about everything
all day long you know people who can't
tie their shoes can tell you about
climate change and you know the rest of
it so it's like you're sort of doing the
reverse of what seemingly most of the
bluejacket Twitterati
is up
you should ignore anybody who has a
sense of complete certainty about a
complicated issue you know unless
they're a surgeon and it's their domain
but if it's just guy on Twitter talking
about climate change or the I don't
trade with China I don't know how do you
figure out who you kind of can listen to
or make some sense out of or something
like that I just help everybody I find
the only way to look at all the windows
as you've got it like figure out what
everybody's saying and then maybe you've
got a little bit of a ability to
determine which one is more sensible
sometimes not yeah does the endless
political part of this kind of make you
crazy like in that everything is
political now right like you talk about
politics a lot pretty much pretty much
every day but I don't strike me as like
a purely political creature well my
interest is actually the psychological
part of it I'm actually completely
uninterested in politics believe it or
not even though I'm like dealing with it
every day I'm interested didn't it in
the age of Trump because of what that
does to our collective psychology and I
think after he's out of office I just
don't know if I'd be interested I mean
I'm not it's not like I'm following
California politics beyond the the fires
in the sidewalk poop right so you think
if things somehow reset to something
that felt more normal or at least the at
least closer to the way things used to
be right to all guys the way things used
to be real boomers here you think that
you might actually just kind of step
away or something like that I don't know
that I could be interested you know if
you imagine any one of the Democrats
winning I I guess I'd be you know super
interested if it were one of the
Socialists because then I might have
right involved as a citizen just to do
something to stop what could be a
cataclysmic problem but other that's now
I just wouldn't be naturally interested
so what do you make about what's going
on with the Democrats right now because
as I said I had you in originally before
Trump was president just at the
beginning and I think I said this to you
last time you were here the second time
one of the reasons I was not surprised
at what happened at the election was
because I heard you and I was like I
think this guy's on to something so if
you were kind of right about that what
do you make of the the split between the
Socialists and then what I would say are
the last vestiges of some sort of
old-school Democrat which is basically
kind of Biden limping along and whoever
else could sort of be considered
moderate there well you know it's really
interesting I've never said this out
loud so this will be just for you um
we're gonna find out you know we're
recording this shoot we're gonna find
out for the first time if the Democrats
have kingmakers because it looks like if
you left it to the public they would
pick Bernie or Elizabeth Warren but
anybody who's paying attention knows
they can't win in the general but and
they also want to win so if they have
kingmakers you're gonna see them emerge
but maybe a little closer to the you
know the nomination itself I don't know
what that will look like and I don't
know if they exist do they exist are
there money people who are just gonna
say look we got to win and these two
candidates aren't gonna get it done so
give us a Buddha judge give us a Tulsi
Gabbard give us a clover chard give us
something else do you not sense that
that's what they tried to do last time
in that Ernie probably had all the
momentum but they just caught him at the
knees and then felt that Hillary was
with the right one so they already tried
the kingmaker thing yeah and it would
almost be too obvious now I mean I think
you're basically right like that does
seem like what's happening here wait
they threw Biden in as the firewall
right
I think Clinton was a special case
because I think she had her own support
and that you know it was pretty deep but
would that support go how does it work
when she's not in it like what does that
look like are they still as active to do
something that would be Hillary like
without a Hillary that's what we're
gonna find out so basically you're
saying if you're Trump you're going oh
please let it be Bernie you're worried
because you just think a numbers wise
it's just like or Biden or Bryden I mean
I throw him in there as they unelectable
so the top three are by far the most
unelectable in the general election
and I feel like why Biden so I get you
on the Bernie Elizabeth thing if people
have just had it with the woke thing in
the far
progressives like bulimia here yeah but
Biden at least seems like he would maybe
bring some of the people that are just
kind of fed up with Trump keep some of
the centrist but you think then all the
woke people would just try to take him
out or something like that well here's a
question I've been asking I've been
asking people even in public have you
ever met
a Biden supporter because you're
laughing because you know you've never
met one yeah I've met a Warren supporter
a bi to you you can go then list but
bhujette sure haven't met you know
Klobuchar but that's because she's low
in the polls right yeah but Biden's at
the top of the polls in fact top of the
polls even in the general against Trump
and I've never met one right or if I'm
out never met one who would it admit it
well I guess there's a certain set of
people that are just like deeply
unenthused who are just like well it's
better than that and so they don't run
around with a Biden sign or something
like that I have to think that people
who are supporting him don't know who
else is in the race and they also
haven't seen him on video recently yeah
because I don't want to be unkind and
when when we first started seeing him I
actually said it in public let's be kind
about this because this won't last long
you know that the party will take care
of it on their own then we'll have a
candidate with full capability but I
feel honestly honestly I feel bad for
him yeah I do too but at the same time I
don't I don't feel like I can pull a
punch anymore if there's something that
needs to be said in the beginning I was
gonna say we'll just let this take care
of itself we don't need to pile on now
maybe we do maybe we do need to pile on
if we see a real problem and I I just
don't think he's got the the mental
capacity especially if you if you fast
forward four years or or god help us
eight years yeah like what what would he
be no eight years well it's ironic cuz I
think a lot of people and obviously you
would not be a bite and supporter but
you are trying to be respectful of a guy
just as a human being but it does seem
like something is degrading there but he
does he's not only a human being but
he's been a great servant of the public
he's apparently well-liked on both sides
I have a lot - good good to say about
him it's just not his time do you think
we're out
focused on politics as a guide it's not
a pure political beast but is you know
framing it for a lot of people I wonder
how many are focused you know if you
walk down on the sidewalk and you said
name a few people running for president
as on the Democrat side how many could
they even name I know could they find
Ukraine on the map to use that exact no
bad I know they can yeah so I feel like
you and I are we were living this
Twitterverse where it seems like it's
the most important thing but maybe it's
not yeah
does that do you think sometimes make it
a little harder to judge what what's
actually going on like you know before
2016 it was like because we existed in
that world we could see something that
other people couldn't see now that world
has sort of collided with mainstream in
a bigger way so it does make it harder
to track some of these things does that
make sense
well I think it's sorry for all of us to
see outside of her bubble so we're all
throw that that's what we're going to
talk about yeah
and so I don't imagine that I'm free
from that the best I can do is you know
use some technique to try to see the
other bubbles as best I can so putting
the effort in the semester you can do
you just can't tell if you're seeing the
whole field that's that's the trouble so
speaking of the bubble let's move it to
the book now first off the top title is
loser think we'll get to the subtitle in
just a sec but when you're titling a
book were you afraid to go if I call
this thing loser think the average guy
and as you know because I just wrote
this thing and we're dealing with titles
and all this stuff it's like you want
them to see it and be able to grab it
but did you think oh if we put this out
there and it says loser think people are
gonna be afraid because they think if
they're gonna touch it that means
they're a loser never sounded like that
what's the persuasion level you were
working with so yes we thought about it
here here's I'll just talk you through
just how we thought about number one I
said if I give it this title will people
ask me why'd you give it this title
isn't that a mistake I go bingo
everybody asked me I just fell right
into the trap right no and that was
anticipated yeah the people would wonder
about too because there exists the
dummies series of books and the idiots
guide it's been proven that people will
buy a book that says they're an idiot on
it and these are two you know this the
series the dummies in the idiots guide
books are enormous so clearly not well
here's the other insight I had because
of Dilbert
when I wrote Dilbert it was of course
making fun of your boss most of the time
but bosses kept buying my material and I
would be like why are you buying it in
my head and they would say this
perfectly describes my boss he thought
it was them yeah so we're primed to
think this is about someone else so I
believe most people are picking this up
and saying one of two things they're
saying haha
this'll be fun we'll mock all those
people and and it does if they want to
see in unproductive thinking techniques
in the book and - this would be a
perfect gift for my brother-in-law and
it'll be like a private junk that that's
the title right so the subtitle is how
untrained brains are ruining America now
that makes a lot of sense to me because
that seems like pretty much everything
that's happening at every level at
academia at the political level at the
media level do you mean it at sort of
every level like just across the board
well it's certainly making everything
worse yeah and the problem is that
everybody thinks they have this thing
called common sense and therefore they
think they're arguing about politics or
priorities or something and often
they're not they're just unproductively
thinking so that the thing they're
saying is actually nonsense it's not an
opinion it's not a priority it's just
sort of nonsense because they they don't
know how to productively think so I
thought well I'll try to make it
accessible instead of writing a you know
how to do logic kind of book which
nobody's going to read I'll just give
you the the friendly anecdote version
that you could absorb pretty easily all
right so if you're trapped in your
bubble and it's becoming a
self-fulfilling prophecy what's the
first step to breaking out of your loser
thing well it's good to know what all
the various parts of losers think are
and I go through them like don't be a
mind reader don't predict the future
with analogies history doesn't predict
slippery slope isn't real yeah Farren I
want to go through a few it yeah so
without details so it's good to know
what those are but beyond that you
should definitely be sampling both sides
of the news
if you're not looking at Fox News and
CNN you don't know what's happening
because I've tried doing that try to
pick a topic and before you've heard
what the other says just consume one
silo and then you go to the other one
you're like what I didn't know anybody
was saying this are you telling me these
facts are real and it doesn't matter
which way you're going they're
completely different but is it almost
impossible to break out of that I mean
we all talk about this all the time with
catering news to ourselves the
algorithms are feeding us things that
you know reinforce our thoughts already
but is it almost impossible to break out
of it because in a weird way
psychologically we don't want to break
out of it I know some people do but that
most of us kind of we just you know not
sound corny wheat that's the safe space
we find and good and we're reinforced
and it's warm this is why I sort of
sneak in the back door if I said to you
Dave I'm gonna get you to change teams
whatever your team is
democratic-republican doesn't matter you
would immediately say or you know you'd
be like it everything you're shooting at
me is bouncing off my force field but if
I say here's how you should think in the
you know in any situation you want to
have something to compare something to a
very simple statement people accept that
because that's just you know reasonable
on that surface and then you take that
through all right now apply this to your
thinking so you can sometimes get people
to talk themselves out of their position
by giving them better tools but you
can't just say change teams because
you're on the wrong team how much is
this do you think is just base human
psychology just sort of the stuff were
born with that certain people are just
sort of more programmed to go to just
things that reinforce their beliefs and
some people are just programmed to
actually being a little bit more open
well I think all of these things have a
you know you're born with a certain set
of gifts and intelligence etc but in
looser think I talked about how you the
experience you've had across domains is
what gives you better vision so for
example if you'd never been exposed to
economics I've got a degree in economics
you wouldn't know how economists think
so you might run into a concept like a
sunk cost and if you'd never been
exposed to this you might say well I
have common sense and people would say
we've already spent all this money so we
better keep in
investing because I don't want to waste
that money I already spent that's not
sensible an economist would say no the
money that's gone should not influence
your next decision because it's gone now
the first time you hear that you say oh
yeah like you don't need to read a book
on it you just hear it and so I tried to
make it as simple as that you just got
to hear it once and they say oh yeah
that makes sense yeah so you don't think
so you think we all have sort of
pre-programmed abilities to be flexible
on some of these things but but you
think that that can pretty much always
be different local sooo yeah yeah I mean
people are more or less locked in more
or less team players more or less
capable of you know looking at details
and thinking properly but everybody can
do it better yeah do you think the
Internet's changing that just relative
to the speed that we get information and
the fact that you can now go out there
and find roughly a gajillion voices in
two minutes that might be able to help
break some of your stuff I'll tell you
the biggest problem I think and this is
brand new thought is that we are as
humans were copiers or imitators so if
you wade into the Internet
what kind of thinking style are you
gonna see the worst and people will
imitate it so they'll say for example
hey your site did X and what's the most
common response your site did actually
yeah yeah what did that help
I helped nothing that wasn't even on the
topic you didn't even talk about your
time if they are gonna do it we have to
do it right so some of it is of course
power and influence and persuasion and
all that nobody's trying to think so you
have to you have to be able to weed out
okay was anybody even trying or were
they just persuading yeah do you think
most of us just don't want to try them
at some level I mean most people just
kind of they don't want to think about
things that seriously because that
brings up a lot of deep existential
sighs yeah maybe you know maybe baby
there's there are lots of reasons we
don't want to be wrong we don't like to
be embarrassed we don't like to change
your mind we don't want to disappoint
the team and we're influenced by what we
see so we just join in and say well
that's what my team is doing I guess
I'll do some of that so you talk about
some of the dumb ideas that are floating
around so that
thus create our own bubbles so I wanted
to go through a couple of them because
we hear these all the time and they sort
of sound right but you don't quite think
they are right we know when history will
repeat itself and when it won't we hear
this all the time history repeats
yes history repeats itself and and
because it has a phrase and we've heard
the phrase we give it weight because the
brain will say well it's a saying I'm
pretty sure I've seen that on a bumper
sticker so there must be something about
that but it's an illusion caused by the
fact that we don't notice when history
doesn't repeat which is most of the time
why is it the history doesn't repeat
because it can't there's never two
situations that are same the variables
have change and if nothing else has
changed you saw what went wrong the last
time so you fix it this time so it's a
complete illusion that we can predict
the future because this time is like
that last time the most you can do is
say people are still selfish stupid at
all those things so if you put it in a
situation where they can steal well sure
they'll steal you know not everybody but
if you have enough people introduced to
a situation where you can steal
something somebody's gonna take a run at
it but that's not really history
repeating right so you would say a
better way to say it would be something
like themes repeat themselves just
because they because it's based in our
nature not the specific event I would
even make it smaller than that I would
say people are people so we you know
they're gonna be selfish and all the
qualities of people so any situation you
put it and put them in you should say
well let's look at cause and effect if I
put that person where the free money is
you know I should expect money to be
taken but not because history repeats
it's just a simple cause and effect so
if it doesn't repeat itself what would
you say to all the history majors right
now that are listening to this well
here's what would be the point of being
a historian if not to have some sort of
roadmap for the future well indeed the
history is what of prevents it from
repeating in some sense because you know
what didn't work so you might see
history repeat when it works so if
something worked before you might see
somebody try to try it again but even
you take anything like North Korea
alright what was the main thing people
said when President Trump got elected
was
while talking to North Korea will never
work all blah and maybe it won't but he
got it further than anybody else he got
it into a personal level it wasn't
anything like history so no matter how
many times history had repeated you
introduced this whole new variable a
president Trump and then history doesn't
count anymore what do you make of that
concept that people who said one thing
two years ago say the complete opposite
and I don't mean that they flipped all
their beliefs but that it's always a
team thing you know it's like if Obama
had talked to gone to North Korea talked
to Kim Jong and they you know a certain
set of people the Republicans in this
case would have been like he's crazy we
can't talk with these people
Trump doesn't we can do it you can flip
that the other way I mean that that I
guess that goes to what you're saying
about the team thing but do you think
people realize the sort of absurdity I'm
not talking about evolving over a period
of time with certain set of opinions I'm
talking that because the players are
different that you just completely taken
opposite yeah one of the great mysteries
is you watch somebody who doesn't agree
with you and they're doing that crazy
thinking like you mentioning and you
watch them and you think yourself is
that real do they really think that yeah
and I spend time doing that too but one
of the advantages I have is having
studied hypnosis
I understand people to be irrational
most of the time and I understand them
to be rationalize errs and I understand
confirmation bias and cognitive
dissonance so my take is that most of
the time they actually believe what
they're saying and because they can't
see it yeah they're the ones who are
blinded to it so it look looks like it
makes sense to them do you think there's
some reason like an obvious sort of
psychological reason that the people who
seem most obsessed by politics on a
day-to-day basis and I'm not talking
about like sort of the broad themes
stuff but as you said before you you're
really sort of uninterested in politics
but the people that are obsessed with
you know the nitty gritty excuse me the
nitty gritty what happened today what
happened tomorrow kind of or what's
happening tomorrow there's a reason that
they're so miserable because it's it's
sort of been like it's like an untenable
system that they're playing with all the
time well you know people are different
so it's probably all different reasons I
do it for entertainment and I think
other people are drawn in from the fight
you know they're like the fight
what's my fight today there's a new
headline let me get into that fight
there's definitely a dopamine or
serotonin and hit that people get just
from making a good points like ah got
that guy said something bad about this
celebrity problem got him some time I
think this was a real fight like
involving weapons they would be much
more reserved what do you think I know I
would yeah exactly
okay let's plow through a couple of
these others that this is a good one
because we hear some version of this all
the time online we can tell the
difference between evidence and
coincidences yeah so we go through our
life thinking that things matter
let me give a perfect example if you
were a fiction writer and you were
writing a book or even reading book and
there was and somebody put on a watch
you'd say to yourself oh later that
watch though I attention to the watch
because the author included that for a
reason so it's easy for some people who
have some experiences to imagine
everything's connected musicians poets
artists they imagine a connected world
because that's what they live in whereas
the economists the scientist the lawyer
if they're not advocating would say oh
you got to look at these you get a look
at all these coincidences individually
and say alright is this real or just a
coincidence so we are we are creatures
who think coincidence matters and if we
don't really police ourselves we create
a bubble by imagining our little
coincidences or meaningful I I give one
example in the book I was walking home
one day and I bought some sharpies
because I like I liked him for a variety
reason so and I took it out of my bag
literally it was hid holding in my hand
and Fox News was on and Greg Gutfeld was
on on his show and he says I love
sharpies I really love sharp is unlike
seriously wallets in my hand yeah and
and how many times have you seen the TV
show there are no coincidences yeah and
what could this mean I so you're saying
that's not the universe talking to you
because we've all had that moment you go
whoa that has some meaning by the way
I've been on Gutfeld show many times
that he loves sharpies I mean the guys
does he's got like a cold thing of
sharpies the sharpies in all his drawers
they're just filled up with sharpies I
know I could have a club of just people
loved show
but do you think truly that there's do
you think there's no chance that there's
meaning in that sort of thing like I
know the Sharpie example is kind of
simple but you know you're having some
deep deep thought and then you're
watching TV and then suddenly a
character says like exactly what you're
thinking now I get it I get you're just
talking about sort of law of averages
also like every now and again this is
gonna happen you're never gonna notice
the ones when it doesn't happen which is
all day long so I get that but do you
think that there's there's no meaning or
value to that well not the examples that
we gave there are there no meanings to
those unless we're simulation and we're
software and there's a little code reuse
going on maybe whatever you know let's
end with the simulation so let's stay
with the book for now but I go to
simulation yes so so short of that it
can mean something in a criminal
situation so if somebody gets killed and
their spouse has booked to fly it out
that morning and they didn't pack the
bag maybe that means something so so
certainly in a political context or I'm
sorry the legal context you have to
track them down but what do you think
buddy what about just in just in a
personal context like if you find
meaning in something that may be purely
coincidental or however else you want to
describe it ridiculous or whatever but
if you personally find some meaning in
it uh here's my advice we're bombarded
with coincidences all the time when they
work in your favor you should say it
well that means something yes that means
I should write this book right that's
telling me that I'm gonna get a check in
the mail and if it looks like a
coincidence that's telling you something
Bad's going to happen you say
coincidence all right seems fair enough
the simplest explanation is usually true
so people like to win arguments by
saying yours is complicated but - a
simple one and the problem is first of
all the world sometimes is complicated
so you know pick any major thing in the
news it's pretty complicated but the
real problem is that we all think our
explanation is the simple one so that's
that's where the cognitive problem comes
in my example I use is how did how did
the world get here well ask the car
and God did it can't get any simpler
than that whoo God did it ask the
scientist who's the evolutionist how did
it all get here gradual change big bang
simple which one is the simple one
well everybody thinks their explanations
is a simple one especially the one
variable people who look at their
complicated set the thing and say well
one variable got it simple it's that one
variable so which was it God or a Big
Bang simulation all right again I do
want to be trying to keep that away from
me okay we will end with simulation then
but sometimes we need some simple
answers right in a complex world do you
think well it helps if you can simplify
but you don't want to oversimplify and
then how do you know how do you know so
every situation is a little bit
different but if certainly if you're
looking at let's say climate change I
want to get into that in a detail but to
just say as I'm shaking my head because
I could barely say this out loud one of
the things I hear the most from the the
skeptics is that the scientists forgot
to account for the Sun the Sun they
claimed that the scientists forgot about
the Sun but they didn't account for
solar flares or solar activity and I
always say the same thing which is
alright it's your job to figure out why
the earth is warm you thought of the Sun
the Sun might be in there you might have
gotten something wrong but it wasn't
because you didn't look at it you know
you thought of the Sun yeah so come up
with a better skepticism scepticism is
fine but if you simplified it to I think
they forgot to look at the Sun you're
not helping yeah that it's funny you
bring up climate change those without
going too far down that rabbit hole it's
it reminds me of something like the
Paris Accords when when first when they
got signed and then when they got you
know retracted or whatever II want to
call it by Trump it was like all these
people like it all sounds good we're
gonna cut these emissions and we're
gonna do this we'll pay for this but it
all kind of sounds good in a simple
sense if you don't think about it and
then we are now out of the Accords from
what I understand we're actually
exceeding many of the limitations right
that were originally signed and there
was no mechanism to force anyone to
actually do anything that it was
literally just people piece of paper but
all these people were
about it like it was the end of the
world and we see this with net
neutrality it was the end of the world
is your internet still working barely
yeah right you had a Wi-Fi problem this
morning but that basically and we sort
of go from end of the world to end of
the world to end of the world situations
yeah we're we're locked into whatever's
the scariest thing you know what's the
scariest thing but with that the example
of the Paris climate Accord if you have
let's say more experience in this world
probably nothing gets solved with that
meeting and we had an agreement and then
everybody kept it that's sort of not the
real world and I think but that just
makes a lot of people feel good right
like when I've when I've mentioned this
and then people confront me about it and
then I say well what was in it or was
any country you know actually was there
any mechanism to force countries to
abide by it or what has happened since
we got out I mean just basic questions
and I'm not saying I'm an expert in this
by any stretch but just asking sort of
the simple questions people that are
that are screaming about it suddenly
admit they know nothing about it
I I think they trusted their side too
much because they've heard it's
important they hear it on the news all
the time must be important do I need to
know the details all the smart people
just said it's important generals and
you know politicians senators if they're
all saying it's important and you're
stuck in your silo and that's all you're
hearing it's reasonable to think it is
without you knowing all the details but
like you said you can you can uncover
that flaw so easily what do you do with
people once once you've sort of
uncovered the flaw and now they're kind
of freaking out because they don't want
that to happen right that that's kind of
scary well I I do the method that you
just described will you do it in
question for him if you do a new
statement for him it bounces off if you
do it in question for him it's like well
what was it about the climate agreement
the Paris climate agreement that you
thought was the good part like what what
was the part that was really going to
make a difference you know how would
that affect China versus how would it
affect the United States what would it
do to employment what would it do to our
economy so I just ask the questions and
let people talk themselves out of it you
can affect people's confidence in the
short-term and then they have to go back
and re-engineer their thoughts
sometimes they might change sometimes
sometimes not oh it's definitely not
always you'll appreciate this a couple
weeks ago I was having a debate I was
having a conversation with with an old
friend about some about the trans issue
and I said I'm completely behind with
trans people obviously I want everyone
to be treated equally with the same laws
and with respect and all those things I
said all I'm saying is that we can't say
that biology doesn't exist that there is
a difference between male and female
that's all I said and he said to me Dave
you're not thinking with quantum physics
and I said can you tell me a little bit
about how quantum physics is related to
this and he goes now you're just trying
to get me ah and I thought that is just
the perfect example of all of this like
he just had this idea that quantum
physics like has something to do if I
could just think in some other realm
then somehow biology of this world would
actually have nothing to do with
anything and then when I asked him about
it he didn't know you might be the best
debater of all time because you chased
him into another dimension reality
there's like no this this is for this
reality is not just disappeared it was
just the smoke just going right that is
it all right stay in your channel yeah
the worst advice yeah you could ever
give or ever get is stick to your day
job stay in your channel stay in your
lane and I hear this all the time
especially when I transition from
cartooning and even before that when I
tried to transition from my cubicle life
to cartooning not a lot of support you
not a lot of people saw that that would
that would work out for me
but if you imagine what would the world
look like if everybody took that advice
well people making bicycles would never
try to make an airplane mm-hmm for one
Steve Jobs wouldn't be an event in any
companies and computers so you go right
down the lane the line and people
leaving their Lane where's all the good
stuff
now I also tell people to build their
talent stacks I call it so if you're
good at this or a few things leave your
lane a little bit and pick up a few
other skills you might get embarrassed
you might get tired but boy are you
gonna be happy when you've got combined
skills that that are practically a
superpower is that another one of those
things where it just sort of depends a
little
about how you're wired like some people
are just all in on one thing and that is
how they can operate their best and some
people are a little more design that
they can maybe change careers more
easily or just learn what learn what
their stack is a little bit more easily
and some people just kind of can't do it
or are you saying that's always your job
to kind of overcome it yeah there's
certainly a personal difference there
are some people who just want to stay
doing what they're doing and do the best
they can and if you're Tiger Woods
that's a great idea
Tiger Woods doesn't also need to know
accounting right well except well maybe
it helped them somebody else is managing
his money and that's never seen so you
can usually tell if you're in that
situation yeah I need to just run on
this this horse as long as I can but for
most of us in just ordinary life I mean
I can only be a high-end cartoonist
because I assembled a bunch of pretty
good skills that anybody could have done
I mean I like a you know a drunken
munkey I like to say but I got better
over time and I got better tools figured
out I had to do it I didn't have any
experience writing humor but I figured
it out over time and had some business
experience so I had a sort of a canvas
to to write on so I'm a perfect example
a bunch of mediocre skills that just
work pretty well together so I want to
back up to something we started with
here about your career because it does
fit sort of loser thing the idea that a
guy who I'm guessing you were probably
decent at both of your day jobs when
they told you probably halfway decent
weight probably not totally in their
election of your duties fair to say I
showed up on time okay you showed up on
time so you were probably pretty decent
at what you did the idea that they said
okay well at two different jobs you know
diversity or in effect the straight
white male like we're just you're
running out of room here that strikes me
is like the worst sort of loser think of
the day like people have tricked
everybody into thinking that that
diversity matters you know I surprised
people when I tell them that I'm not I
don't have a feeling about those times
that you would expect I don't feel I
don't feel like society made a mistake
because sometimes you need to use a
hammer and sometimes you need to use the
scalpel and you
to know the difference in those days
when there was literally just no
diversity in senior management of two
major companies in the Bay Area for the
newspaper to get on them about it I
think that's how happened the newspaper
got a perfectly appropriate and for them
to say look this is a this is a
sledgehammer situation and today you're
the nail mm-hmm I remember thinking of
it it's like that's actually a pretty
good societal goal and in fact we're
much closer to that reality far better
diversity I think we're better off I
think it was good I just happened to be
on the wrong side of the sledgehammer at
that so while it was bad for me I don't
have an activist opinion that shouldn't
have happened because I think it got us
to a better place that's interesting but
do you think that part of the problem is
that we sort of take a sledgehammer to
everything now so I don't fully agree
with the premise there but but because I
just think those things are bad no
matter what it's it's just to against
the individual for my personal taste but
I'll go with you
do you think that the problem now is
that so much has changed we have
diversity pretty much everywhere in many
ways it benefits you and I'm not talking
about diversity of thought I'm talking
about diversity of your color and gender
the rest of it but we're still always
hitting everything with a sledgehammer
now and we don't go in with with the
sort of softer tools yeah I'm very much
well I guess my feeling is that if
you've got slavery you need your biggest
weapon the civil war if you've got no
civil rights then you need the civil
right movement marching the streets
smaller than the nuclear weapon and I
think we've gotten to the point where
you're talking about things like
institutional racism and which in which
case my preference is to teach strategy
because there does exist you know some
amount of bias etc that will affect some
amount of people but we're we now live
in the world where everybody can find a
place where the bias works for them for
there there's no fortune 500 company who
doesn't want to hire a qualified woman
black person gay LGBTQ you name it they
all want them if you walk in the door
and you've got the right degree you know
right experience
and you say and also you got a job so if
you're not teaching the strategy instead
of worrying about this one place you
can't get a job leave they're so happy
how do you move then if you've succeeded
using the hammer it's hard to give up
that hammer right well for in the
political terms you know going big is
always good you know you you want to be
a Oh see if you're gonna be the new
politician it's like what's the biggest
thing I can say to send everybody's hair
on fire
and then if I need to back up world's
ending at 12 years again it's pretty
good
persuasion why it's pretty good set and
then you shrink it back as you need it
but it's you know I try not to try not
to confuse the the hyperbole and the
politics with what's the right tool
right do you think AOC is just like some
other version of trumps I'm like reverse
version of Trump just using those same
things she is the real deal
so I identified her early on people who
have similar backgrounds Mike sort of
itch for example almost identically the
same time we just said Oh watch out for
this one this is before she was a OC she
didn't even have the AOC name yet yeah
and sure enough she was she was like a
rocket and everybody could see it now I
believe that her spirit back story is
that she was selected in kind of almost
an American Idol fashion yeah people
don't know their YouTube videos that
people can check this out rush they like
basically picked her right yeah she
ticked off all the box so and of all the
candidates she was she was the strongest
one so we should not be surprised that
she performs better than a random person
so as a guy though that likes or at the
very least understands Trump's use of
persuasion and go big scale back now
watching AOC do it and I'm guessing you
probably agree with many less of her
policies are you worried that that's all
politics will become whoever has it or
has the ship already sailed is that just
where we are now I guess so well first
of all I would say she she uses
hyperbole the same way Trump did so when
Trump was running for president and he
was talking about you know rounding up
14 million illegals I just said that's
not gonna happen so I never really took
that seriously when she says we're gonna
die in 12 years I don't really take this
but are they persuading in the right
direction
is it good to have tight border security
that you can decide to open it up as
much as you need or close it when you
need to yes that would just be a good
system no matter how many people you
decide to let in right that's like the
conversation that's a separate question
similar with a or C she's got an
interest in climate change I think the
scientists have made a case that co2
warms things I know some people watching
this will disagree but but most of the
scientists say that now there's
certainly questions about the
predictions and what's gonna happen in
the future and I would differ there but
she is she is moving people in a way
that they weren't moved to before it
probably is an issue or thee of movement
some of the crazy things I think she
would have to pull back if she were
national candidate and I think she would
but is there just a general danger we
don't have to make this about her
specifically that if politics just
becomes sort of people throwing out just
every theory without really knowing
anything behind it so I guess I can't
make that not really about her cuz I
just don't think she's that bright I
mean I just don't I think she's being
you know they selected her and now I
think she's being manipulated and they
took a sort of pretty girl who just
likes getting up there and saying
anything and and that that strikes me is
actually dangerous well I completely
disagree on her intelligence and
capability yeah well no I'm not saying
her capabilities not good I think she's
playing a role so the capability is
there but the I think the actual
intelligence behind it I don't think is
that great maybe I think maybe we're
talking about a different type of
intelligence here certainly she has the
political intelligence she has a
psychological intelligence social
intelligence geez obviously you know
there was more than most people about
the topics because of her job but I
would say that she's a productive part
of the conversation because you need
somebody that strong on these big issues
like climate change so that you know you
you know you're getting a good good
back-and-forth and it meets somewhere in
the sensible middle so I think she's a
productive part of the conversation even
when I don't don't agree with her all
right well let me give you the S here's
a test okay
a very simple test to find out
she's smart or not the answer to climate
change even if you don't think it's a
problem is generation four nuclear or at
least being pro nuclear if you see her
never come out in favor of nuclear as
part of I like where you going with this
as part of the solution then she is
abandoned and reason because even the
people in our side Cory Booker there's
several of the people running for
president most of them are not though
right that's a half and a half or
something so I think three I know I care
American might be yang but some of the
smartest people I think yang is four I
think yeah we should confirm that
believe so but some of the smartest
people are running as Democrats are
already there and really that will tell
you is she is she just playing it for
effect or does she want to solve the
problem all right that's that's an
interesting take I guess we'll see in
the next couple monsters well well I
guess we ultimately find out depending
on where Bernie Falls against it but I'm
pretty sure Bernie's against nuclear
right or it is again she's now a Bernie
surrogate so maybe she's not as smart as
you think well she's I understand she
started with Bernie and she's probably
mostly influenced by him and Bernie by
the way I have so much respect for
Bernie while hating his policies man
that guy's a force of nature he really
changed the change the conversation I
don't want it to go where he wants to go
but I love the fact that he's he's got
to introduce this body of thought
alright all this sensible talk aside
let's shift for these last few minutes
into the simulation because I see this
conversation happening a little bit here
and there and on some other podcasts and
thing I don't know that we've really
ever talked about it on this show before
what do you mean the world could be a
simulation well it is all this crazy
tongue let me say first of all that
smart people also agree with this so
Elon Musk for example has a similar view
this comes from Nick Bostrom a physicist
so serious people and in fact in Silicon
Valley near where I am it's very common
for people to believe this is true but
you don't talk about it too much
you're going to find out why the dinner
parties you find out white people don't
talk about it yeah so the idea is that
we're our current world is approaching a
place where we could create a software
simulation of little creatures in the
simulated world that are just software
who would act and believe if you use
that word that they're real now maybe
we're not quite there but you could
certainly imagine in your lifetime we'll
be there and easily maybe ten years
twenty years so the thinking is that if
it ever happens by any civilization
it'll happen lots of times and if it's
such a good simulation the creatures in
the simulation will someday create their
own simulation mm-hmm
now what would you look for to find out
if we're a software simulation who
thinks we're real or an original species
well here the some of the things you
would do if it's software first thing
you do is that you would we would not
create all of the history you would
create it on demand so for example if we
discover a new planet that would never
be written until we see it now in
physics can we show that an observation
causes a wave to collapse I don't know
what I'm talking about right now by the
way this because because when I get into
physics it gets all yeah yeah let me
till wave collapse but but it's
generally true that you needed a
subjective or a machine the observation
of so you know upon someone's I give up
you have a little spit of areolas yeah
okay all right jump from wave wave
collapsing so the idea is that even in
physics we know that you need an
observer or a machine observer I think
to collapse reality in other words
things don't exist except in probability
on the quantum level as if I know what
I'm talking about here again until
somebody observes it so that's how
exactly how you could build software it
doesn't exist until you see it you would
also say all right you little software
people can't get outside the reality of
that we defined because if you could you
could see what you're in can you get to
the edge of the universe you can't ever
get there because because speed of light
will keep you from ever doing it so you
see you see all of these coincidences
that are exactly compatible with how a
software programmer would program a
world then you look at the odds the odds
of being an original when there will be
so many copies one in a trillion
one in a million we don't know maybe
it's one in three but the odds are
certainly much favouring the simulation
and not that we're in original species
so basically that's the plot of the
matrix if we had to kind of Whittle this
into something here
well that's we're sort of the batteries
for this when the main old thing in the
matrix there are real people and they're
also a simulation and they're sort of
coexisting and this we're just a
simulation would it matter you know what
I mean like let's all we found out right
now we're in it like let's say we became
self-aware within the simulation what
we're still in the simulation no matter
what I guess that could alter how we
would deal with the simulations we would
create well let me ask you though and
this is just for fun sure I don't don't
anybody take this dishonestly one of the
things you might imagine is if somebody
could realize they're in a simulation
that they could hack it
who believes in the simulation Elon Musk
how is he doing
[Laughter]
rocket to Mars for god sakes he put a
Tesla in space just because he could how
am i doing Dilbert worked out okay I've
got the best book that's ever been
written according to me things are going
really well we got it so look for people
who believe in the simulation and then
say to yourself how does it going and
you're gonna find a pattern that will
blow your brain out so you're saying
whether I believe in the simulation or
not I probably should just try to
believe in it a little bit more the
people who you're saying if this is a
simulation that if I believe it's a
simulation this video will be monetized
I think that's what you're saying let's
concentrate really hard monetize
monetize yes I believe that you will
find a way to vast monetization if you
accept accept pray with me the
simulation that Scott Adams is how you
end an interview on YouTube you guys can
follow Scott at Scott Adam says on the
Twitter whether this is a simulation or
not and don't forget to share this video
in all our videos with friends family
and foes you can just click the little
share thing right down there thanks
everybody if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversation
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell